oh right it's a little better I think
get this going okay
ah yes airs out makes it a good day ah
how's everyone doing today
hufflepuff from Maryland how was your
date my date wasn't bad actually the
last few days have been alright which is
good cuz I went through I don't know
about two solid weeks of not good so
this week so far well I mean I had a
good weekend too I had a good weekend
it's been a pretty pretty good week all
things considered so yeah I'm actually
I'm doing alright
do you watch agents of shield on no I I
eased off halfway through season three
it wasn't like I made a deliberate
choice like I'm not watching that
anymore but I fell behind and then I
just didn't feel like catching up and I
just didn't and I just didn't I've heard
it got better again but you know then I
came across the thing that always throws
me off which is time and not having
enough of it and I just realized I
forgot something give me one second knew
something was missing
ah there we go that's better good places
ending with season four thoughts
probably for the best
I'm looking forward to it I'm sad it's
gonna end but I have an awful lot of
confidence in Michael sure that he's
gonna end it well hey Carolyn that time
there's no issue with the TARDIS
yeah well get me a tour
and that'll be fine so I don't know if I
don't know if anyone's wondering about
the title like I I mentioned that I have
had a decent weekend I'm a decent you
know a few days but it's been funny
because it was weird I start to I wonder
about this sometimes it seems like when
things go better for me they go worse
for people around me and people who I
care about and the last couple days
especially a surprising number of people
who are important to me have had really
rough times for a variety of reasons
from you know physical issues financial
issues emotional issues mental health
issues there's been like a litany of
stuff hitting so many people who who are
friends of mine and that's that's been a
little bit rough but I'm going to in the
spirit of something that was sent to my
p.o box over the weekend and to
paraphrase some what I know they in Game
of Thrones they said that this is what
we say to death but for me I feel like
this is what we can say to the darkness
even if it's within ourselves so
hey there trans gamer girl good to have
you here hello darkness my old friend
yes uh it's true it's always there get
what delicious water would you like the
Daleks and the Cybermen to engage in
combat again maybe um I would have said
no before but since they kind of did the
upgrade on the Cybermen um with
nightmare and silver which is not an
episode I like very much but we're gonna
upgrade the Cybermen that much to the
point where they might actually be a
threat to the Dalek sure I'd see a
rematch on that with that basis what if
the doctor faced off against Thanos I
mean given the doctors tiny Y meanness
I'm not sure it would be that different
than one Doctor Strange kinda did his
whole thing as someone who doesn't
follow Doctor Who I appreciate your
video but the issues going on
surrounding one of the writers important
to stay informed about these things even
if it's not in your sphere I mean if I
I'm glad you enjoyed the video it's
actually I tend to go out of my way to
not dig into that stuff too much if it's
outside of my wheelhouse because I deal
with enough of it within my geek dumbs
and to seek it out outside of that and
I'm not saying there's a problem with
being informed that I wouldn't
discourage any more from doing that but
like for my own state of mind only so
much I can I can take in need to get get
a drink for any over asked questions yes
you do this this is important stuff how
are you I'm doing all right I know what
you mean my mother my uncle just passed
right before Father's Day finding the
silver lining yeah it's you know losing
people that you care about and Oh Joe
stopping in in the middle of working on
tomorrow's thumbnail uh and folks asking
him how exams went yeah like it's I
think that my thumbnail guy just drops
in it was like hey how's school been
this is love this
do you have a movie most people hate but
you love um I have a like not most
people but there are movies that I love
that like uh a fair chunk of people I
know hey like there are movies that are
like the you either love it or hate it
thing that I fall on the love side of
although I hesitate to called the the
majority but like I love repoed the
Genetic Opera and I got some people who
hate that movie so much I don't have as
many interesting answers to that
question as you think I think largely
because I don't go in for the so bad
it's good thing so if I find something
to be genuinely bad it's hard for me to
find too much enjoyment out of it or at
least that last very much way random
question okay Meg what do you get what
are your thoughts on Dan Howell and
Eugene from the try guys coming out um I
don't know what I'm enough about them I
mean somebody linked um Dan Howells
video to think it might have been my my
barrier gays video and I did I did watch
most of it and he seems like a nice guy
but I have no idea who he is I probably
should he's huge evidently going by
subscriber numbers um but yeah I anyone
taking the time and the energy and the
risk to come out has my respect
on that basis does that mean they get a
free pass on everything
no again I don't know these people but I
mean the funny thing about coming out is
the risk of it involved in it never goes
away the nature of the risk changes
depending on you know with something
like YouTube on the size of your
audience um because you're always
risking a hit by coming out and it's a
question of whether or not you can tank
the hit like I really do worry when I
first came out about a year and a half
ago January of last year
that I was really afraid that that was
gonna tank my channel that was just
gonna just completely nosedive it and
kill my prospects um whereas someone
like like Dan Howell obviously there is
still risk involved he could still lose
a significant chunk of subscribers
depending on what things he chooses to
talk about he may lose advertisers but
he's not gonna be wiped off the platform
by you know he's not gonna lose however
many million he has I had ten thousand
when I came out and that scared the
ever-loving crap out of me coming out as
a permanent process not one-time event
for sure yeah you're never really done
coming out a little late cuz I was
walking my dog but I'm here now
it's okay we've only been going for
about ten minutes or so
you're good don't worry about it what's
your favorite Harry Potter movie for a
movie it's probably half love Prince I
think I really like the mood and the the
vibe on that one not my favorite book
though I do have different rankings for
the books in the movies what was the
last anime you watched ooh that is a
good question I don't know uh-huh now
I'm embarrassed honestly I don't know I
don't know what the last one was been a
little while what do you think of the
new doctor who sees and it should be
good I mean it's shooting I have nothing
to go off of the only thing I have to go
off of because I don't deal too much in
the rumor mill is the the Judoon image
that came out I did my video on that
like I might I am a hopeful for the next
series of Doctor Who because I want to
see it grow and evolve um but I don't
know what'll happen I kind of need to
see more before I'm gonna get excited
about it did you check out the boys
trailer I did see it I'm not I might
give that
maybe an episode or two I don't I know
this is sacrilege in a lot of areas but
I'm not a huge fan of Garth Ennis and
like I couldn't finish preacher and
while I love welcome back Frank his
Punisher stuff got odd for me after a
while like Garth and this is a talented
guy but I would say he's about 70% as
clever as he thinks he is so that kind
of grates on me after a while what
you've been watching TV in the
background yes I have I have paused
something I'm that I'm in the middle of
working my way through for a review but
I'm not gonna say what it is here
because only the patreon supporters get
to know the docket in in advance or at
least in detail and this is actually
patreon sponsor review I'm working my
way through so you'll you'll see
eventually ah see have you heard about
the upcoming movie Jungle Cruise it was
all okay okay so I'm gonna read the
question but I almost stopped have you
heard about the upcoming Disney movie
Jungle Cruise it will apparently have a
first openly gay character and any
Disney movie ever to my understanding
that is still not entirely clear last I
knew there was a leaked story that Jack
White House character was not only going
to be openly gay but be flamboyantly
like fabulously gay which was something
that was denied and I don't think Disney
ever officially confirmed that the
character is gay at all so I don't have
an opinion cuz I don't know how accurate
that is if it ever got confirmed I
missed it
would you want to see the doctor reunite
with Susan and would Susan call Jody
grandfather well but if Susan ever comes
back
whoever the doctor is Susan should call
that them grandfather I don't care if
it's Jody or another woman or whatever
whether
she should ever come back I don't know
huh the thing is she's like part of me
wants that but part of me also thinks
she has been gone for so long and
they're only gonna get one chance to
reunite them and if they get it wrong
I just there'd be so much riding on it
that it really the prospect of them
tackling it scares me to be honest
did you see Godzilla - king of the
monsters everybody drink uh and if you
have one of your thoughts I've not
gotten to it I there's there's a number
of movies that I very much want to see
that I either have not had the time or I
flat-out missing the theater or they
didn't come to my local theater that I
have a growing pile of to be streamed as
soon as they're available movies from
this year and that is probably gonna end
up as one of them if you could have a
billion dollars in cash but an immortal
snail is always following you and if the
snail touches you you die would you take
the money that is really elaborate also
know like I'm I'm doing okay right now
without a billion dollars and I don't
need that stress in my life a favorite
non comic-book superhero movie um oh
jeez trying to think of the non comic
book ones I'm not gonna come up with
them off the top my head like you got to
give me a list of options or something I
mean I suppose you could count
unbreakable that would be in contention
not sure what else something oh well
Incredibles I think s that will probably
be it the first one didn't really like
the second one
hi there heavenly imaginings Mystery Men
is actually based off of a comic so that
one doesn't count
kick-ass is based off a comic that
doesn't count you got to remember folks
just cuz it's not based off Marvel or DC
doesn't mean it's not based on a comic
there are other comic publishers out
there could you do more middle-earth
stuff please I think it's unexplored
area of your channel there isn't much to
talk about on the middle-earth front I
mean I supposedly Amazon still working
on you know doing their own take on it
but like there's nothing new and I feel
like people way better at this than me
have already picked to the bones clean
of the Lord of the Rings and The Hobbit
films or have written a whole academic
treatises on the original works I I
kinda feel like I have nothing to
contribute to that conversation right
now have you read any of the Doctor Who
comics not like the formal stuff I've
read one Doctor Who comics so far which
was a free comic book day so and like
it's it's hard to tell how you know how
representative that is cuz Free Comic
Book Day comics are weird in case anyone
cares Susan did return to Meets The
Sixth Doctor and a Big Finish audio
which story cuz now I'm curious and I
might want to look into that do you
think it's weird I love The Hobbit
movies all three extended editions that
is yes I find that incredibly weird I
mean good good for you I'm happy for you
I hate them
that last one especially I hate them a
lot
I think the Hobbit left a bad taste in
people's mouths and Lindsey Ellis did a
fabulous job of covering out oh yeah
like I I don't think I would ever have
it in me to tackle anything that Lindsey
Ellis already did a video on because I
look at what
didn't went well there's nothing more
for me to say now she's too good at this
like it in a disheartening way she's too
good yeah that's weird the habis movie
Hobbit movies are an embarrassment I
don't like don't be cruel yeah you don't
have to yuck somebody's YUM
I don't like him either everybody but
you know let's let's not overdo it is
there something wrong with me that I
don't mind fear her no I honestly don't
mind it it's not good but it doesn't
offend me the way that stuff that I
really dislike does in some way do you
think the solar track should have
appeared as Susan in the hopes that the
doctor stays or maybe we don't see Susan
we just see Jody's reaction and here
Susan's voice that's all a lot of people
propose that as what they wished would
have happened this is this is in the
Doctor Who episode it takes you away I
would have been down for it but like I
also don't have a problem with the Frog
and I feel like for some people the push
of that as a alternative is because they
don't like the Frog and I kind of do so
maybe I'm weird now like that's not a
maybe I'm pretty sure I'm weird um okay
so it is Lantern is the best Doctor Who
episode see you're just trying to bait
me with that one so we'll move on from
that
have you seen Chernobyl yet everybody
drink no I haven't I don't have HBO
anymore I ditched it as soon as the game
of thrones ended ah when is weird a bad
thing never said it was just said I'm
pretty sure that it's something that I
am ah jobs done now I can continue and
waste away my sleep schedule by devoting
my full attention to the stream welcome
then Joel and I can't help I see you put
job's done with the exclamation boy I
can't help but hear the the orc peon
voice from Warcraft jobs good I'm really
glad that actually Blizzard still uses
that because I remember that from
freaking Warcraft two tides of Darkness
is where I first heard that boy I am old
hell-bent was a master beep yeah
couldn't even get through a good yeah ah
ah
Muppets fan oh yeah
lovers are great I love the Muppets
they're fantastic
everyone's weird in their own little way
oh yeah absolutely
did you watch the Legion season 3
trailer no I didn't realize it had
dropped I'm not sure I'd expect much to
get from it cuz I I loved Legion but I
bitterly understand it so I would expect
to not really follow the trailer anyway
uh if you thought The Hobbit movies were
bad wait until Jackson tackles The
Silmarillion not even funny
don't even joke though it's not even
about Jackson no one should be trying to
make a movie out of The Silmarillion hey
that's that's that's a terrible idea a
channel pump made a video where he tried
to both spies the gareth roberts thing
can we write him off as an edge lord no
no you can't cuz if he was an edge lord
he would have taken a much harsher
position on one side of the or the other
and then really decried or belittled
whatever was the opposite side I I mean
I saw his video and given his youth and
his very him being very open about his
lack of experience with a lot of the
things that were being touched on and I
thought he did him I thought he did a
perfectly fine video I mean do I agree
with the position he landed on no but
for what his understanding was I thought
the video was fine is it bad I've
watched the Planet of the UN's more
times than I can count but I always skip
when help and turn
into a nude no no that's like that's how
I would have preferred to watch it if
I'm being honest
have you seen the new frozen trailer um
I did I find it interesting because we
got our first kind of hint at like a
solid hint at a story which is it looks
like they're gonna be delving a little
bit into where where else's powers
actually come from and that is actually
a pretty decent place to go with the
story because it went completely
unexplored in the first one which was
fine we didn't need to know but it
leaves an honestly a pretty big sort of
dangling thread to pull on and see what
story nuggets you yield so um I mean I'm
still nervous about it I'm not I haven't
loved a lot of the animated sequels that
I've seen in the last few years so like
with the exception of lego movie 2 which
is better than the first one
fight me but I it's a solid enough
premise for a frozen - let's go with
that what's the movie that you hate that
a lot of people seem to like or is like
critically-acclaimed I think the big one
is the shining I don't like the shining
at all I don't think it works worth a
dang The Silmarillion is just a fancy
telephone books so many names I mean
like so Marillion is is effectively the
middle-earth Bible and is written about
as dryly as the Old Testament is so
Disney Princess team up movie anyone
well you know what if they did that I
guess I would consider that to be the
one good thing that could come out of
the wreck-it Ralph
sequel cuz I actually did like the
princess scenes in that I can't pay
[ __ ] pledge but I appreciate the hell
out of viewing your channel just wanted
to thank you thank you Spencer ie I
appreciate that and again obviously I
appreciate the the patreon support but
like whatever you know just watching bad
that helps did you get a My Little Pony
added a lesbian
Kanon couple I did not cool that works
have you ever watched BBC's Merlin I
haven't I feel like I need to add that
to the list of drink questions because I
feel like that one gets asked not every
stream but fairly regularly no I never
did see it so you and Stephen King agree
on that at least true although I don't
use that as a basis for why I don't like
The Shining cuz sigh more in the book
but yeah favorite cars movie I've only
seen the first one so by default the
first one I suppose best non companion
female character in Doctor Who Missy
like your views haven't seen them all
nobody has but I like how you stay
objective were some other reviewers
stray from their objectives into a
random sea I don't claim to be objective
I try to be fair so like you if you
think I stay objective you might not
have done some of my rant e'er reviews
because when stuff rubs me the wrong way
I can go off but I do try to be fair and
have a substantive reason for that and
you know avoid doing things like
attacking the motives of the creators of
the stuff and to acknowledge the
strengths if I do if I do see some there
but I I am capable of going off on some
stuff but the ranty reviews are so
wonderful and you justify the read like
that's the best I can hope for when I
get into that and to that space I'm like
I hope that it's just justified how much
I'm gonna tear into this thing the
dragon and Arthur's actor
I can't follow that sorry
not true they're such fun to watch is it
weird okay is this like the meme of this
thing is it weird that is that the thing
is it weird that I'm excited to watch
the Downton Abbey movie I mean if you
like Downton Abbey the show I guess that
tracks I never watched it myself you
reviewed the player of games did you let
the hair down or not the LGB the book
has a lot of LGBTQ related stuff in it I
have shot that reviews but no I didn't
bring my hate I didn't let my hair down
for that because it is just an aspect of
the book and an aspect of my review of
it but it's not the primary focus of it
and usually I take the hair down when
that's the main thrust of what it is I'm
talking about so no I didn't for that
video which will be out Friday but I
absolutely talk about those aspects of
the book do you have any interest in the
upcoming Wheel of Time series on Amazon
I never read the books so I don't know
what distinguishes them from any other
epic fantasy series so I don't have a
reason to get excited
I'd like to know what player of games is
exactly please I'll fill you enough to
the stream job Joel has to make a
thumbnail for that purview and he has
any but you're one in it's a book well
we'll talk at this tree I'm sorry
sometimes I spray stuff bye Joel or I
don't properly prep him just like I need
a thumbnail for this he's like ah I
don't know what that is thanks for
putting up with me Joel maybe I feel
different about William Grantham because
me and him are closer in age I'm 26 he's
22 I mean like that can that can impact
people's feelings about things you know
how you judge someone for better or for
worse if they are within your generation
or closer to your your age Thank You
Connor whether you watch it or not as a
child would you believe the Thomas the
Tank Engine and friends have been on
television for 35 years
yeah I'd absolutely believe that I
didn't watch it as a child
but my kid didn't have like a few DVDs
of it and ya know it looks like it's
from been around that long some of the
old stuff yeah I could look at that
actually I'm almost kind of surprised
it's only 35 cuz I can look at then go
oh yeah that's 70s but you're telling me
it certifies like no it's not crap
that's newer than I am
dang would you like a Tobey Maguire
Uncle Ben kami or someone new in the MCU
just as a picture of flashback uh Tobey
Maguire no cuz he's too young
they'd have to slap him in old-age
makeup and I mean we just look like
garbage
I mean I suppose he wouldn't have to be
that old if he was gonna be paired with
Marissa Tomei I don't know that that's a
little too cheeky for my taste and
honestly I kind of feel like it's better
just to leave it alone because if they
were gonna do something like that they
needed to do it back in homecoming doing
it several installments later just would
draw too much attention to it I think
if there was a new Doctor Who TV or
cinema movie what would you like it to
be I have no idea because like what
would you do with a movie that you
wouldn't just do in say your average
two-parter like it would just give
bigger but especially when it comes to
something like Doctor Who where the best
episodes are heady and you know they're
big on banter and character interaction
I don't think bigger is gonna be
something that I'm like oh yay
is it weird that I asked you preferred
pronouns given make given that you'd
already know the answer and you know
that's a drink question no it's not
weird just sneaky would you sign up to
HBO again if you knew Russell T Davies
had a new sci-fi show on there well if
you're referring to years and years I do
know and I've had plenty people ask me
if I'm watching that the I like the
issue I've got right now is um I don't
have I'm not sure I have time for it
like I'm trying desperately to get ahead
with the stuff I've already got and it's
like I'm already trying to figure out
how the heck I'm gonna get Jessica Jones
season three and and where the heck I'm
gonna deal with that but like slotting
in another thing even if it's only six
episodes long I just
barring somebody commissioning me to
review it I'm probably I'm at least
gonna miss talking about years and years
being anything timely like I'll get to
it eventually I'm sure and I might even
do a video on it but it's not gonna be
like I guess it's just wrapped up I'm
not gonna get to it like where it's
where it's still something people are
talking about I'm not gonna get to it
that quickly I found out that today is
autistic Pride Day oh I was not aware a
happy autistic pride then
much love Chad have a great day thank
you for the heart Spencer
much appreciated if you had to choose
only one companion for Doctor Who series
11 Graham Ryan or yeas slightly odd
choice but it's because of the way you
were to the question if it's only one
than yes because Ryan and Granton
because even though I've called you as
the dead weight and I stand by that for
what we've gotten so far
grandma Ryan are a package deal either
one of them on their own I don't think
would work nearly as well so if it's
only going to be one companion I think
it should be yes and we get a chance to
actually flesh her out and have her work
which she doesn't currently I'm late
well you know just get a pregnancy test
cross your fingers that'll be fine
have you seen insert movie or TV show
here yet
no I haven't haha you said you were
worried about people saying why can't
you bring stark back if they introduced
alternate universe to the MCU doesn't
the Tron times doesn't the time travel
stuff create that issue um not really
okay so we got a backtrack here so get
my endgame a review and also in other
things leading up to I talked about how
I don't want the introduction of
alternate universes like we and let me
clarify I'm not talking about things
like the quantum verse or the mirror
dimensions or the dark I'm not talking
about alternate planes of reality I'm
talking about parallel universes that
are effectively the same as ours and
part of the reason I don't want the MCU
to ever definitively introduce those is
because I don't it's just gonna result
in a whole bunch of fans whining that we
should be able to get characters who are
dead back in because we can yank them
from the other alternate dimension now I
actually do consider the the way that
the MCU handled time travel to be a
different beast because the
set interesting rules around it in terms
of what you could or couldn't do and
what you could or couldn't sort of
remove from the timeline and not have a
break everything and I think the way
that that was laid out was done in such
a way that I think they can justify not
doing something like going back and
saving Tony Oh God
Torchwood will fall when the bad wolf
hybrid knocks four times to the Silence
of the timeless child known as Saxon on
trenzalore ah god I was like every
mystery box just hit me in the face
ah did you like Dark Phoenix I haven't
seen Dark Phoenix it did not come to my
local theater like at all they even open
they even built a new screen it's now
four screens at my local theater they
still didn't get it can I attempt to
create a banner for you mate by all
means I make no promises about using
stuff but like if people want to make
stuff for me I will never say no and if
I actually do intend to use it we'll
figure something out as far as you know
possible conversation goes but yeah if
you want to send me something for fun
that's fine if you want to send me
something say hey do you want to be able
to use this we'll talk about it once I
see it do you have a list of your
favorite movies of all time yeah but I
don't oh um I actually do have written
down somewhere like in any Cell sheet
where I broke it out by genre cuz I'm a
dork like that do you think the timeless
child Ark will be resolved in Jody's
last episode maybe series 12 do you
think it was intentional or just bait
for viewers to stick around I hope it
was nothing I hope I hope that the
dropping of something like the timeless
Chou
was just nothing I don't like I'm so
sick of it so sick of that ah I think
they're gonna use alternate timelines to
bring Loki and Gamora back well they
don't have to bring Gamora back she's
already back and Loki they're not going
to because they're giving him a spinoff
show on Disney Plus that's covering him
during the time when he was alive so I
don't think so in either case oh god the
flying muffins Oh
Marvel character do you most want to see
added to the MCU the action as far as
the actual films go Kamala Khan um she
hopes the runner-up but I want her to
get her own TV show the alternate Loki
is what the show is about right possibly
and like that's the fan speculation but
the show of being confirmed before that
and what have been said is what it was
gonna cover Loki's you know sort of
jumping through time messing with people
before you know a lot of stuff that
we've seen go down but fans speculation
is that it actually deals with a Loki
that kind of got away in and game but
that's unconfirmed as far as I know did
you make a video about hi guardians
spice or did I imagine it I don't even
know what that is so I think you dreamed
that one Dakota mhay is my friend she
also believes in flying muffins and the
flying muffins ever had to battle the
Flying Spaghetti Monster that's my first
question
I'd love to see Squirrel Girl make an
appearance in the MCU I would be very
down for Squirrel Girl she-hulk law
procedural comedy-drama series that
would rock yeah that's basically my
pitch for the she-hulk TV show like it's
it
Ally McBeal dealing with superhero law
and she's six foot three in green like
that's a show
I want Squirrel Girl in animation I mean
I think she's a better fit for animation
but I wouldn't be opposed to see her in
live-action but I think the nature of
her humor generally leans more towards
animation what are your thoughts on yaz
getting more focused in series 12 subbed
by Chris Chibnall confirmed she's back
in the police force and you dude are
coming do you think they'll tie in both
together
I mean maybe here's my general thing you
asked any more of a focus of series 12
is kind of needed if she's gonna be
sticking around but here's the thing
even if they get if they do good stuff
with her in series 12 I'm still gonna be
left going she was she was dead waiting
series 11 and the best I'm gonna come
away with is going okay she works now
you shouldn't have introduced her until
series 12 that's my sort of predictive
assessment I don't know what I'll
actually think we'll see when I see it
but that's that's my guess at how I
might end up feeling about that I
confused it with the video from mr.
enter I don't know who that is either
goodness like to hear you talk about the
promotion of the series if you think it
will not see the light again I have to
look this stuff up cuz I have no idea
what any of this stuff is talking about
is is it weird I dreamt I met you like
you were in full full burlesque ear in
the middle of a supermarket here's my
question you say full burlesque ear like
was it a specific outfit that I've been
in or was it like the more generic
burlesque II stuff of like a corset and
a bustle and like big feather headpiece
thing like paint me a picture please
kind of lost with the doctors
regenerations like is the Peter Cushing
brain of Morbius past doctor and the
word doctors in the regeneration cycle
okay the war doctor counts Peter Cushing
does not and the brain of Morbius stuff
is
was set up to imply that they were
earlier versions of the doctor but that
is no longer considered to be canon
so that basically got retcon peter
cushing doctor was never canon and war
doctors absolutely canon is it most of
season 11 dead way oh that's a little
harsh
like I have my issues with but there is
there is good stuff there too when I got
you to read my favorite book I was
initially like he'll he'll love it oh
hang on sorry I lost this dang it
where'd it go
ah sorry I had something up and then the
chat like jumped on me to go ah there it
is when I got you to read my favorite
book I was initially like he'll love it
then a few days later I was like he'll
hate it and help me to be emotionally
prepared for that I didn't hate it
alright I hope that helps
I did I did not hate it or do you think
a bore of the Boy George biopic being
played by a woman
wait is that a thing all right are we
are we just running through queer music
icon biopics is that is that the new hot
ticket I mean I guess between Rocket Man
and Bohemian Rhapsody how well do Rocket
Man do though I don't keep an eye on box
office very much anymore um I mean I
liked it but I don't know how big a hit
it actually was I dreamt that I met him
in his Slytherin burlesque outfit at a
convention like that that would actually
be viable that you could actually do
that okay so I remember it was similar
to your outfit last week with the dark
lip and leather outfit but also had a
dragon filled with a pair of purple
wings it was a look hahaha that that
doesn't sound that far off from
something I do so cool
have you heard the theory that Loki
looks the way he looks because he saw
owns memories of hella when he carried
him so he took on his appearance
I hadn't heard that cuz I don't do fan
theory a lot i buy that sounds viable
I'm not like invested I'm cool
that's neat enough idea rocket man is at
a hundred thirty four million worldwide
currently ooh that's on the low end um
that's probably barely in the break-even
range then do you have any tattoos
I do not unblemished top to bottom I got
nothing I was drew I I dreamed I was
running around my high school naked I
haven't done that what I do I do
frustratingly still have well I was
gonna say I still have the I mean that
I'm in for a test that I haven't set pay
for dreams except I don't quite um I
have the burlesque version of that which
is I'm backstage getting ready for a
show and I don't have my outfit and my
music isn't cued up and I don't have
time to do my makeup so stupid things
piercings at just the ears would you
like Loki to shows gender fluidity in
the TV show since he is gender fluid in
mythology I mean I think that would be
cool
I've read some of the comics with the
the female version of Loki which was
very neat um I expect that if they did
touch on that in the show it would be as
like a one episode bit of fun I got
something they delve into but I'd like
to see it sure oh ok excuse me folks got
a band somebody here there we go
I think it's issue as to why it isn't
doing well as I'd wish talking about
Rahman here because of the movies that's
going against I mean and I'm like for
Aladdin detective Pikachu accept it well
men black for isn't performing well I
know that as well I mean it honestly it
strikes me as odd that they released
Rocket Man in the summer it's not a
blockbuster movie I mean maybe they were
counting on they were expecting to be
counter-programming
but yeah I don't uh I don't know why
they chose to release it at the time
they did I would have pegged it more for
uh an early yeah an early spring or a
fall release for that one troll in the
chat yeah I got him my thoughts on
Charlie Brooker saying he would like to
write an episode of Doctor Who please
yes I don't know what that it looks like
but I want to know huh hang on folks got
another one did like word go out or
something oh no I'm let me get rid of
this guy alright and I don't mean to
generalize by saying guy but sorry it's
usually guys the funny thing is I'm
prone to lucid dreaming so halfway
through I was like why am i embarrassed
none of this is real
yeah I never couldn't do the lucid
dreaming because basically the instant I
realized oh I'm in a dream is the point
at which I start to wake up did you hear
about the new producer in charge of
live-action Star Wars I did not like who
and when and like just producer on the
film's are we like talking head of the
student like you gotta you gotta give me
more than that
I thought son killing Eve never seen it
who's Charlie Brook Charlie Brooker is
the creator and primary writer for Black
Mirror another regeneration question it
was said that the doctor could only
regenerate 12 times so total of 13
incarnations that he would die so what
was his supposed last regeneration
before the new cycle
Matt Smith was his final regeneration of
his original cycle because you have okay
see if I can go through this yet william
hartnell patrick troughton Jon Pertwee
Tom Baker Peter Davison Colin Baker
Sylvester McCoy
Peter McGann the war doctor this is
going chronologically within his own
timeline Christopher Eccleston David
Tennant David Tennant again because he
burned through a regeneration when he
siphoned off his stuff into the hand
that was in journey's end and then Smith
was the thirteenth so Tennant to Smith
was the 12th regeneration Smith was the
13th so in the time of the doctor that
he had to be granted a whole new
regeneration cycle so Peter Capaldi's
the first one in the news cycle it's
frightening to me that I knew all that
off the top of my head so the doctor has
never regenerated female before Jodie
the doctor has not no other Time Lords
have but not the doctor
Zen dears a brilliant artist oh god yeah
that piece that I put up in the in the
comment comments thing on the on the
feet and I also shared it on twitter
like oh god that I had so much fun
getting that I got that over the weekend
I was actually backstage at the
burlesque show that I was in on Saturday
and I'm showing that around like
somebody drew me how cool is that that's
a lot of fun oh we got more trolls that
I miss did I it's hard to keep up with
these sometimes so hang on
just sorry guys just check him for
something here ah there we go man there
they're out in force - this time I
wonder if I like God on the trolls radar
because I did the because I did the the
pride stream cuz I expected them to come
out for that but apparently they they're
still coming out even after which I'm a
little surprised by do you think there's
an extra component for Time Lord
regenerate into the opposite gender if
it was random chances it should happen
more often funnily enough I made that
exact argument about four years ago
because it pardon part of me is annoyed
that it's at this point still one of my
most viewed videos but I did a video
ages ago basically saying why I thought
the concept of the doctor regenerating
into a woman was a problem now realize I
actually made this video before um Jodie
Whittaker was announced actually was
before even compiled he had announced he
was leaving it was after the reveal of
Missy I made this video because I
immediately went you start a clock
they're gonna do it with the doctor at
some point and initially I had a problem
with it and one of the things I brought
up in that video which again I'm not
gonna say I don't stand by anymore I
leave it up because like it reflected my
thoughts at the time and I thought yeah
I wasn't a jackass about at least I
don't think I was but I brought that up
that if it was random chance it should
have happened before now but that
assumes that it's a 50/50 chance just
because there's there's two Wow
theoretically two options male or female
we could get a non-binary doctor that'd
be awesome
but anyways you're going on the same
assumption that I did which was that oh
well if the doctor either regenerates as
a man or woman should be a 50/50 chance
it should have happened before now but
for all we don't know enough about
regeneration for all we know it could be
a 1 in 50 random chance that the dog
that a timer regenerates into the gender
that
weren't in previously like we don't know
the the specifics or the statistics
given how rare it is but we do know that
it happens that leads to one of two
conclusions either it's something they
do voluntarily but the doctor clearly
was surprised by it and also the other
times we've seen it um they seem a
little bit like oh okay I'm this now and
they don't seem like they were prepped
for it so that would lead me to believe
it is a random chance but it's it's like
it's like winning the lottery maybe not
that astronomical of odds but odds are
against it but there's a chance for it
it's like you know what it is it's your
odds of a critical success or a critical
failure on a d20 role there you go
how's that for a geeky comparison haha I
don't count Tennant his two incarnations
only is using two regenerations yeah I
mean that's how I count it - did he
burned off a regeneration but I don't I
don't count them separately are being
gender fluid and non-binary the same
thing Oh gender fluid is a type of
non-binary um or at least it can be
because gender fluid varies from person
person some people are gender fluid you
know flow back and forth between very
rigidly defined male or female for
myself I kind of go in-between and hang
out in the middle non-binary is just
anything that is not the rigid
male/female definition now most people
who identify as non-binary they use that
to mean that they their sense of gender
if this is male and this is female
there's somewhere in here but most
non-binary people are people who
identify that way it's a fixed point
whatever there are their gender identity
is on the spectrum it stays there or as
a gender fluid person it goes back and
forth and for someone like me who does
have a middle ground there is a
non-binary aspect to it but I don't
usually identify that way not because
it's necessarily inaccurate just because
what most people mean when they say non
by
marry isn't what I am I feel like
gender-fluid just just the nature of
what those two combined words means it
describes me better great now I want a
doctor who DD episode
are you watching episode 9 yeah of
course I'm gonna watch it I'm nervous
for it but of course I'm gonna watch it
oh dear how are you feeling about having
to see dr. veena Joe I bring whiskey or
vodka
um Jager I think that'd be good for that
one yes correct about non-binary people
oh good
uh-huh that's that's a relief because as
much as I talk about this stuff I do
worry about getting stuff wrong because
I have at various points I've misspoken
and I've gotten things wrong or I've
made assumptions that weren't right
I'm guys the thing you folks you gotta
remember my information is based off my
own life experience and the people who I
know I'm not an academic I have not
deeply researched a lot of this stuff I
couldn't write a thesis on it not a not
a well sighted one every at least so I
do get nervous about getting stuff wrong
one more than last like mirror up so be
up Monday okay another regeneration
question that's been the running theme
of this um Matt said the doctor is
a-comin and Peter said I have a word to
say to the next doctor so is the doctor
spirit like the watcher version the
watcher thing is very anomalous if
you're trying to properly track out
regeneration lore The Watcher doesn't
really fit anything so it depends on
what kind of fan you are if you're like
me who is aware enough of the meta
reason which was when they were
generated Tom Baker they try something a
little bit different than they never did
it again and I don't give too much
weight to it then you just sort of go
yeah and move on if you're the kind of
person who really needs it all to fit
together
makes sense there are probably theories
out there as to exactly what the deal
with the watcher was in that
regeneration but because I'm not that
kind of person
I'm not that kind of fan where I
absolutely need everything to fit
together I don't know a ton about those
theories or how they work a green haired
doctor I like whenever I see dyed green
hair you forgot a gender as a type of
non-binary that is true very valid um
like I had the thing about green hair is
that while it can look great when you
when the first kids died and I've got
I've got like a burlesque friend who
who's been having green hair lately she
looks great because she refreshes it
regularly Green is like one of those
colors that fades really badly it's uh
huh yeah a gender oak okay
I'm not entirely sure how well I can
describe a gender um because I don't
know how well I understand it but here
is my understanding of it so obviously
when you're talking gender you've got
male you got female you've got gender
fluid you've got your non-binary
somewhere in between a gender doesn't
have the scale this entire spectrum
chuck it out
they have no particularly strong sense
of any gender identity at all so it's
not even non-binary oh it's like I have
a gender it's just not these things that
most people are used to referring to
which is what non-binary is a gender is
saying yeah I don't belong on this scape
yo I don't belong in this spectrum
anywhere so a gender means a lack of a
sense of gender at all and again I don't
know what ton about it cuz I don't I
don't think I know anyone pearlies
personally who's a gender um I've got a
number of friends who are who are
asexual um I've got a number of
non-binary friends I don't personally
know anyone a gender so like if I got
that wrong at all
all forgive me please you think that if
a story with an overweight character
mentions consequences of being
overweight like health issues or
problems getting a partner is it fat
shaming ah potentially not automatically
because as is always the case it's
always gonna come down to specific
execution just like you know having a
story about a trans character where
being trans is a cause for them to have
depression or they are hedonistic or any
of the really bad cliche or even if
they're predatory and all the bad
cliches that are hurled at trans people
doesn't automatically mean that the
story you're telling that has those
elements is that it makes it very
possible it makes it a really big
potential problem but it's not automatic
it is possible to take problematic
components and thread them through a
story that actually makes them work how
do you do that I don't know but it is
possible
given how Time Lords literally change
body gendered terms for them would be
very different yeah one would think time
to mention I went to Pride this weekend
and it was lovely to be with people like
me to be honest it was so accepting and
fun to be with others like me it I went
through a point about eight years ago
and guess where I kind of questioned
whether pride was still something we
needed and I look back at that now and I
think that that was a silly thing but I
think a lot of that was I and I could
slow my criticisms about some pride
elements sometimes but what I what I
really have an appreciation for these
days especially is it is deathly
important that people who are able to
are visible because otherwise
those who are lgbtq+ who are not out or
still coming to a sense themselves for
if they can see just see much less go
and be present and among people who are
in any way like them like people need
that so it's yeah it's important
emailing you my gender paper I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna grade it for you
even with the gay marriage being
legalized in both our nation's we lgbtq+
still have a long way to go
no yeah no it's absolutely true like my
oh god do we do we pick up another troll
no for goodness sake
ah alright let's see here sorry give me
a second mm mm ah
God's sake actually you know what I'm
pretty sure it's the same person cuz at
least two if not three of these people
have had the same icon for it so I'm
pretty sure it's actually the same
person just coming back over and over
and over again like what I don't
understand that is a use of your time I
mean it I just don't get it what's in
the mug water
when you review player of games do you
talk about the ethics of what special
circumstances does um not in detail i
allude to it a bit because i do talk
about some of the moral grayness that
gets touched on that i kinda wish have
been delved into a little bit more the
parade by anti LGBT bigots is terrible
and gets criticized a lot in an ally
circles well yeah it's that if there's
odd stuff trolls are the same people who
close the door with their hips not even
sure what that means
i like sir being more gender neutral now
maybe lord is the same like let's just
have lord be the new title yo you the
waiter comes up to your table
so what are my lords having this evening
I'd be down for that I'll be so awesome
a best season of black mirror I I don't
know because like I think of them so
much as on an episode by episode debate
by episode by episode basis I can't even
off the top my head remember which ones
are wearing which season so it's just
not how I categorize the things should
dude be gender neutral yes I should
[ __ ] I use them gender-neutral II
personally so this was uh there's a
conversation I have with my mother and
I'm not gonna say who we were talking
about but we were talking about someone
who we both find incredibly frustrating
and I said censoring slightly I said I I
can't stand that woman and my my mother
said don't don't call her a woman please
and this
wasn't like a trans thing it wasn't like
that she just was irritated by the
association with her gender because my
mother you know is and was a feminist so
she took offense to that as so she I
said can I call her a [ __ ] does she
wait yes that's fine don't call her a
woman but you can call her that I don't
know I I found it amusing basically all
the books aside from player of game is
deal with the Essex of SC it's kind of
odd the odd one out in that regard
that's kind of interesting
we need Andrew Scott as next master
disagree i how i think he would play it
is a bit too close to how John Simm
played it when he first showed up I mean
maybe he'd do something else but like my
idea of like what I picture him doing it
um yeah it basically just aligns with
that ya know another troll I got him see
I feel like insulting female dogs is
just plain mean fair
sam neill is the master that would be
interesting I'm sis heading straight
pride is the dumbest thing I've ever
heard
but here's here's the thing about the
straight pride is they try and make the
argument that like well you guys have
probably should have pride to accept
they completely give away their true
intentions by the fact that he wanted to
have it in the same month as gay pride
like if you just wanted to celebrate
straight pride why would you put it in
direct competition
we gave right because you're you're
doing it as a retaliation and you're
giving away your your motives you reveal
too much
Shrek as the master Oh God
that's that's a--that's a painful
thought Missy is the best modern master
I do agree with that if we're sticking
to the show if we include Big Finish
derek jacobi if you've heard the war
master series gives her a run for her
money
best Pixar film um I'm still partial to
up but I always I also have the very
unpopular opinion that Pixar as a
company is overrated overrated is not
the same as bad but I do think they're
overrated
have you seen Andrew Scott in the film
pride no so many people have been
bringing up that film to me ever since I
did my list of my favorite lgbtq+ focus
movies - I did that oh no I was last so
it was about a month ago a lot of people
mention that movie to me but I haven't
seen it yet as a straight man I can say
we got straight pride every day I mean
you know it's huh it was like some of
the replies to the barrier days video I
did was like well what about all of the
straight white men who get killed in
movies I'm like yes but there's 12
others literally standing around you're
covered
you're losing one is it a drop in the
bucket and it's this kind of same thing
with straight pride losing a day or even
a month to people who aren't straight
you still got the rest of the year where
you are the standard have you seen what
we do in the shadows I have not I'm
nervous like I worry that it dips too
much into the cringe enos like from the
clips I've seen
sorry
anyone considered Charles dances the
master I mean he could do it for sure I
almost wonder if he's like too obvious
choice favorite Don Bluth film um
secrets and NIM would be me and for that
this is just oh that just lapsed into uh
into screensaver mode I've had it paused
for too long see hold on I missed
something here all right pardon me let
me just take care of something here
sorry guys I think I keep nice you say
dude is general neutral I have a
tendency to use guys as a gender gender
neutral collective I keep trying to
break that habit but I'm sorry I keep
missing like stuff is going on the chat
I keep having to deal with these trolls
it's it's it's annoying but they shall
not beat me I'm pissed right now cuz my
dad's got the nerve to call flying the
pride flag the same as people who fly
the Confederate bye wow wow okay that's
I don't even know how to say what to say
to that that's Yanks
can you explain why you don't like the
shining I'm curious
I am neither engaged by the characters
nor frightened by the situation I mean
that's that's the simplest way to put it
uh-uh wait he doesn't like the shining
yeah I mentioned that earlier I don't I
don't like it
have you read The Shining nope Emily
Blunt is the Rani and Patrick Stewart as
the monkeys sit like people what this is
a big part of why I don't personally fan
cast very much is because people tend to
think of who's already famous what I
want more than anything is to dis is to
see somebody who I don't know what to
expect from that I mean that was a big
part of why I really loved Matt Smith as
the doctor I never heard of the guy
almost nobody had ever heard of the guy
nobody knew what to expect from him and
then he showed up started doing this
thing and I was like I didn't know what
to expect but I love what I got and that
like I want that more than I want to see
somebody huge and famous be these
well-known Doctor Who characters put my
trust into Google and found out what
player of games is you'll find the
completed thumbnail your inbox Thank You
Joel you go above and beyond my good man
shining is one of the least good Kubrick
films like there's only a couple of
Kubrick films that I dig anyways and
that's part of it yeah I think it needs
that element of surprise I mean if you
can get it it's hard to get um but if we
can find it I'd prefer it I have yet to
find any Stanley Kubrick film I've
gotten into I've really only got two and
one of them I like if I watch it for the
first time now I probably wouldn't dig
it as much I saw it when I was in
college which was the right age for me
to see it that was Clarke work or injure
and I also liked dr. Strangelove that's
kind of it though Cooper don't really
work for me
Kubrick was so cruel to Shelley Duvall
Welk Rubik was Kubrick was
he's a bit of a jerk you a fan of the TV
show Lost I've only ever seen in the
first season I did like it I haven't
ever bothered to see the rest of it my
partner Liz likes it a lot including the
ending she likes the finale
shirred Martha ever return I'm not sure
what you do with her I I don't I don't
know oh for God's sake all right hold on
folks here we go again
do you did you clear that off there we
go have you seen an ash vs. Evil Dead I
did the first couple of episodes but I
think I think maybe I've grown out of
ash as a character it's just like a
little too much I don't know I I don't I
think it's fine I don't think there was
anything wrong with it or that it failed
to capture what evil did was I think I
just kind of grew out of it I think is
what happened is Nathaniel is on a kill
streak at this point yeah I totally
should have kept a tally pretty sure up
to six at this point uh dr. Strangelove
and Barry Lyndon are my faves aside from
that I recognize his films are genius
but they're not for me yeah I Kubrick is
one of those directors who I'm like I
would never say that his movies aren't
good and that's all like let me clean I
don't I don't think the shining is bad I
just don't like it that's all I feel
about most of his movies I don't think
2001 is bad I just only like about a
third of it ah so funny how that works
out run always is really good I've heard
that how's your evening going just got
here well I'm having to clipped rolls
left and right but other than that it's
not too bad
do you prefer flying muffins or
anti-gravity avocados oh boy that is a
as a tough call I think I'll let that
battle just play out in the comments I
tried to think of something really
clever to say that no I like
instead but like I'm most of the way
through my water so I'm not quite as
quippy as I might otherwise be
the girl who plays Ronnie and Sarah Jane
Adventures has been spotted with a
series 12 director thoughts none because
that's behind the scenes rumor stuff
there's always all sorts of people on
set until I see something official I
have no thoughts this is why I avoid the
rumor mill oh here we go again
uh do you do do do you think you might
like dr. sleep despite your dislike in
the shining
I am oddly curious about dr. sleep like
I saw the trailer and I'm like I'm
intrigued that might be one where I wait
to see you know reviews from some
critics that I trust and then go from
there
holy cow what a night yeah I know right
it's been weird that's okay uh what's
the most LGBT phobic thing you've ever
seen in a movie I don't know off the top
my head like a lot of stuff I try to
just cleanse from my mind so try not to
dwell on it I'm sure I've seen some
stuff but like most of the stuff that
would have that in movies like III
Corden on to that before I ever sit down
to watch it like I wouldn't have I
wouldn't have known to call it that at
the time but like the original Ace
Ventura movie is frightening ly
transphobic bow from the birdcage bow
from the birdcage is the worst oh man
Val uh if anyone hasn't rewatched the
birdcage lately Val the son he is
terrible he's an awful human being and
that one's frustrating cuz I feel like
the film doesn't realize he's awful
Silver Lining of what I talked about
that way way way way back at the start
of the livestream I've just had a lot of
um
people who I care about a lot of friends
just be having a really hard time lately
and and I just trying to you know keep
things on on the upper side upper side
what am I even talking about I'll have
another drink I'm gonna have to wrap it
up soon because I think my coherency is
degrading rapidly this is strong water
that's that's what's going on here
silver lining of the Dalek have a sip of
water
my mommy called had to talk to her know
that's important keep in touch with your
mother assuming your mother is good for
you to keep in touch with I also have
friends are like the best thing they
ever did was stop talking to their
mothers which is sad but like sometimes
we pops on The Fresh Prince of bel-air
thing is one of the money's the most
educational timeless shows ever I didn't
watch it heavily what did I heard but no
it's um it's pretty it's holds up pretty
well surprisingly
water aka thirsty juice
all right I think I'm gonna wrap it up
thoughts on the Golden Girls that's a
fun show that's that that show is just a
fun at time thirsty equals water hungry
banks question special special
circumstances in the other books but
it's very clear that he thinks the fact
that minds tell them what to do next
makes it ethical that's a little
unsettling you gotta be honest
troll number nine oh dang it I missed
another one oh god I gotta keep an eye
out for that um for that icon cuz they
keep using it
do you like Gotham Scarecrow it's okay
he didn't do much honestly
full moon must be relieving this month
if you have a trolled means you're
popular I'll take it I mean like if I
for certain kinds of people if I have
riled them up properly I take that as
meaning I did something right
have you okay I'm adding this to and
until until it starts airing I am adding
this to the drink questions do you know
that season for the good places last
season I dunno I think it's probably for
the best
everybody drink so it was like Hydra the
trolls ah cut one head two more all rise
yeah but you know the Hydra also got
killed and there it is again
BAM how do they get new emails so fast
oh I'm sure they have this stuff set up
well in advance and I'm also pretty sure
I'm not the only person they harass like
I'm sure they do this to a ton of other
people trolls who can't spell trolls
can't handle the gay I know right man
the fragile these folks um ten trolls
new high score you know that you know
what I feel like that that's a good
point to bow out on
roll score of ten calling it a night so
thanks everybody for tuning in and like
I said I know I know definitely like a
lot of people I care about a lot of
friends of mine are going through tough
times if anybody watching this is going
through a hard time I hope that it is
short-lived and that things start to go
into into a better place for you because
like the darkness is something that we
all deal with but it's it's not forever
it comes it lasts it can seem like it
won't pass but it does and for me at
least I had the strength to go to the
darker elements and the trolls so thank
you for tuning in and thank you in
general remember folks you're beautiful
you are loved you are ballad you are the
council
I'm just running meetings I'll see you
again in a week